my favorite thing ever which i've yet to
achieve is i want to have a kid
that's like my dream well pump the
brakes pete
kim kardashian is not quite ready for
more kids at least not yet i do feel
like
my house is so full but in the best way
while keat has been going strong a
source tells e.t quote kim is getting
more and more serious about her career
as a lawyer and she's not necessarily
thinking about having more kids at the
moment but on the flip side pete he
recently told kevin hart he's ready to
be called dead
it would be so fun to dress up a little
dude like you know like you saw it's
just like i'm so excited for like that
chapter
still kim and pete have had a deep
connection since the reality star's
hosting debut on saturday night live
back in october
i did snl and then when we kissed in
scene
it was just a vibe and i was like oh
maybe
maybe i just need to try something
different
good news we'll get to see more of the
couple's relationship in season two of
the kardashians including some steamy
scenes like this one they teased in the
trailer that dropped earlier this week
life is good i have a new boyfriend i'm
just having a really good time babe yeah
do you want to shower with me really
quick
while pete appears to be literally
dropping everything for kim our et
source adds that pete and kim are not
totally at the point of having children
together but they're still having a ton
of fun together it should be very fun
and based off what we've seen the
lovebirds are definitely enjoying each
other's company we've seen them take
romantic tropical trips together
and pete passed the ultimate boyfriend
test with flying colors by catching
kim's best angles for her instagram pics
you're gonna know your angle you have to
know you know the lighting is everything
and when the snl alum and kim aren't
soaking up time on vacay they're sharing
glimpses of their everyday lives
here's kim looking cozy with her feet
literally kicked up on her man
it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing we're told
kim feels like she's in the best place
in her life and is so comfortable with
pete our source adds the skim's founder
love sharing cute moments from their
relationship with her fans and plans to
continue doing that i was like why not
[Music]
you